you
well I think certainly some incumbents
are in danger although I think that some
of the media characterization of the
election as an anti-incumbent wave has
been overblown the fact is that in all
of these primary elections so far only
one house incumbent has actually been
defeated one and two Senate incumbents
but in both of those cases I think there
were actually special reasons behind
their losses I mean Arlen Specter
switched parties about a year before the
election and really gave Democrats very
little reason to vote for him here's a
guy who'd been a Republican all of his
career Democrats in Pennsylvania were
used to voting against him he switches
parties and basically the rationale he
gives is that well I needed to do this
to survive so you know I think there
that it had more to do with the
particular circumstances of part the
party switching by Arlen Specter and you
know then in the the the Utah case you
know you had not a primary election but
a very small party convention dominated
by the most conservative activists in
the Republican Party in Utah which is a
pretty conservative state to begin with
so I just wouldn't want to read too much
you know into that now there's no
question when voters are discontented
over the economy and the state of the
country that they tend to vote against
the party in power and so in addition to
the fact that it's a midterm election
and the president's party almost always
you know loses seats in midterm
elections and the Democrats are in a
rather defensive posture anyway because
they've picked up so many seats in the
last two elections many of which are
actually in Republican territory you
know so you've got a lot of Democratic
incumbents running this year who are
representing states and districts that
you know have usually voted Republican
in the past so my expectation is that
the Democrats will lose a substantial
number of seats and and so you know
quite a few Democratic incumbents will
lose but that's more a reflection of
just the normal kind of partisan swings
that we see in elections and especially
in midterm elections rather than any
unusual level of voter anger and
moreover I think it's very misleading I
think to try to read too much into the
results of these primary elections or
special elections that have been taking
place you know I think that is a
tendency on the part of the media often
to over-interpret you know the latest
event whatever just happened is always
the most important thing that's ever
happened we saw this during the
presidential campaign you know both the
primaries and the general election
campaign Reverend Wright you know was
when that when that event happened oh
that was the end of Obama's candidacy
well it wasn't and again you know during
the general election campaign all the
furor over surrounding the choice of
Sarah Palin as John McCain's running
mate well that turned out to be
overblown you know so I think we're
seeing the same thing this year every
time some new interesting event takes
place whether it's a incumbent losing in
a primary you know or special election
outcome the media jump on that and and
try to read you know into that some
great significance for what's going to
happen in November I think that that is
really overblown
you